(grunts)
- I got it, I got it.
- You're on the inside, of
course you're going to get it.
- Well, I still got it.
(elevator bell rings)
- box out, box out, box out,
box out, box out.
- Hey.
- What?
- I'm on the arm rest.
- Jump ball, jump ball (grunts)
- Every time you buy me a lunch,
I deduct that from the
concert ticket expense.
- We're going back to Van Halen?
- It's win by two we've
always said it's win by two!
- I don't recall it!
- Done, I'm already
done, I'm already done.
- Ah, it hurts so bad.
- The difference between you making pro
and you not making pro was about
eight inches of height and
then like being talented.
- Know what I just thought of?
- What?
- Nut Tap!
- (grunts)
- Shotgun!
- Punch buggy!
- Ow! (censor beeps)
- You're telling me right
now, that Mrs. Krestbow
was hotter than Mrs. McKinley.
- She was hotter after she had the baby.
- She had bigger boobs, yes.
- I can get lower.
- That makes her look
hotter than your wife.
- No, what!?
- You get the white controller.
- What the shit?
- Your feet smell awful.
- They smell fine, they smell
like an athlete's feet should.
- I can burp better than you.
(burps)
- Make or take it, it's
my ball, make or take it.
- It's not make or take it!
- All out, bar fight brawl right now.
- I would literally knock your head off.
- Pee yourself in front of these women!
- You're telling me Fred
Taylor is better than Brunell?
- I'm telling you that Fred
Taylor is better than Brunell.
- How are we related?
- Sort of does look like the runt, so.
- Wait, what did you just say?
- What the (censor
beeps) did you just say?
- What'd you (censor beeps) brother?
- Alright Okay, okay,
- Okay, Alright.
- (laughs) Nerd!
- Sorry I was being such
a (censor beeps) earlier.
- It's alright man, we're brothers.
- Nut tap!
- (grunts)
- Aww, you (censor beeps),
aww you (censor beeps).
(xylophone music)
- With some of that, and some of that.
- Look it, I'm popping.